secretary of state
for defense wallace ladies and gentlemen
i welcome you all
today we are at together at mikhail
kogal nicano air base united for
eastern flank and for strengthening the
allied security of the black sea
the light force resides in the unity of
its members the romanians the british
and the citizens of all the other allied
states
must know that they benefit from the
strongest security guarantees
nato is a strong alliance
the united kingdom is a major strategic
partner for romania
thank you once again uh secretary of
state for defense for your leadership
and persistent commitment for the
enhanced air policing missions in
romania the british royal air force has
been with the romanian air force since
2017.
today we welcome the fourth uh rotation
in mihail
of the british detachment with four
typhoon fighter jets
boris johnson
federation
uh
we're listening to a live press
conference with the defense secretary
ben wallace who is in romania we're
expecting him to talk about the attack
this morning on
the train station in cremator square
it's understood at least 30 people have
died and more than 100 have been injured
it comes after he spoke earlier and said
that the uk
could do more and will do more and they
were increasing the number of raf planes
being sent
to
near the area um
as i said it's defense secretary ben
wallace and his romanian counterpart
speaking at a news conference let's
listen for rounds of negotiations have
failed
this morning i reviewed with uh my
counterpart the latest developments in
the serious security situation in
ukraine russia's invasion of ukraine has
significantly changed the regional
security paradigm and the level of
threat on nato's eastern flank
we discussed the concrete support given
to ukraine in these extremely difficult
times
the humanitarian hub in sujava massively
supports the collection and
transportation of international donation
for ukrainian neighbors
[Music]
well we're going to leave this press
conference for now and get a bit more on
ukraine um but we will come back to it
as soon as defense secretary ben wallace
starts
talking
now more than 30 people as we've been
saying have reportedly been killed at a
railway station in the east of the
country the station was being used to
evacuate civilians at the time of the
attack leading to further accusations of
russian war crimes it follows a day
where vladimir putin's spokesman
dismissed such accusations as fakes and
lies in an exclusive interview with sky
news
ukrainian authorities say the attack
happened at a train station in donetsk
where thousands of civilians have been
preparing to evacuate to safer regions
as russia focuses its troops on eastern
ukraine
sky's jason farrell sent us the latest
on the attack
well we've had reports of two missiles
hitting the railway station at
kramatorsk which is in the dunes region
of ukraine this is an area where
officials have been saying that
civilians should try to flee there's
concerns about an oncoming russian
invasion of renewed invasion from russia
as they regroup and prepare to
concentrate
on that particular region in the donbass
to try and get gains there so civilians
have been fleeing those regions and it
would be expected that there would be a
large number of civilians
getting to railway stations trying to
get out of that region
we understand from early reports from
the railway station that according to
operational data they say more than 30
people
were killed and more than a hundred
wounded this would be people fleeing
their homes trying to get away from the
conflict and dmitry peskov in that
interview with mark austin yesterday was
saying that the ukrainians were using
civilians as human shields discouraging
them from leaving he was saying but
these are ukrainians who are trying to
get out trying to get to safety
apparently being hit on that journey
by russian missiles that would be a very
worrying development as russia continues
to deny causing civilian casualties in
this conflict
let's get some reaction to what's
happened in kramertorsk joining me now
is svetlana zali shook a former
ukrainian mp
svetlana what do you understand about
what's happened at the train
station as you've said already
many people die 30 people died more than
100 people are wounded at the moment as
you understand russia is regrouping its
troops
and ukrainian military forces ukrainian
leadership is expecting
a more a tougher blow on the eastern
part of ukraine on donetska and luganska
region so chromatorus is located in this
donetsk region and many people are
trying to get evacuated after this news
in recent days so of course it was
packed the railway tradition uh station
was just packed with
people with children with elderly people
with a lot of women and
this is very cynical that these
missiles have been shoot uh on the
railway uh station with so-called
tactical operational missile complex
it's called torchka so they knew
where do they what are they going uh to
hit so this is unprovoked and
unjustifiable attack which is definitely
qualified as war crimes
so another really significant attack
what does it mean for the people trying
to leave what other options are
available
i think that people are scared and
frightened at the moment
first of all to stay where they are
because they understand that attacks are
coming but at the same time to leave
because they understand that
there are no such things as green
corridors because green word is even
when they agreed and guaranteed by
russians russians do not honor their
commitments and we know that already
dozens if not hundreds people have been
killed during this evocation agreed
evocation processes
and
you know railway actually so far has
been one of the
more or less kind of safe way of
traveling uh but at this point we see
that actually it is not and at any
moment of time you can be killed you can
be hit by a missile wherever you are and
i also want to raise the issue and this
is my personal kind of uh
question rhetoric question if you want
today ursula van der leyen the
president of european commission is
traveling by by ukrainian train on
ukrainian railway uh to cave and i'm
wondering is it actually russian sending
a message to the leadership of of europe
that actually you know what you're not
go you can be safe even if you're
sitting on one of these ukrainian trains
do you think it was the right thing for
her to do though to take that journey
well
this is one of the problems that we face
now in ukraine that russians are
fighting ukrainians not only
on the ground
that there is also battlefield in the
information sphere and you mentioned
already and you've shown these pieces of
the interviews with uh peskov and
interviews with putin and they are
denying war crimes crimes against
humanity that they're committed i'm
afraid we're going to have to leave it
there and we're now going back live to
ben wallace the defense secretary
speaking in romania really again
it's very easy and nato to forget that
the south of nato is as important as the
north very often the media focus comes
on
northern atlantic
but you know the south of nato whether
that's romania or the black sea or
bulgaria always central europe is just
as important it's where we see russia
pose a threat sub threshold and
sometimes directly in areas like the
black sea and often very aggressively
challenge our exercising a freedom of
navigation or indeed freedom to fly in
our own airspaces
and that's why it's really important
that nato's
leadership in delivering a message to
putin that the alliance
is how we are going to stand up to his
bullying and his threats
and i'm grateful for romania's
leadership in standing strong and tall
in the light of a very aggressive
uh russia at the moment
certainly they are on the front line
they are one of the countries such as
poland and romania who are on the front
line
from the potential overspill or indeed
a more aggressive russia
the fact that romania has sent troops to
poland uh to help in poland is in a
tremendous sign of partnership and
teamwork and it is that partnership and
teamwork that sets us apart from russia
because we ultimately share the same
values of democracy and freedom rule of
law
and freedom of the press
something that sometimes
politicians all of all colors and all
countries deal with but it is the one of
the most important
aspects of our freedom of democracy a
free press
and if you doubt that just go and ask
the people of russia who won't know why
their young soldiers are coming back in
body bags they will be told some
fictitious story
not very far away this morning in a
place called krampus
what appears to be russian missiles
struck
civilian people queuing for trains to
seek a safer place from the war
the striking of civilian critical
infrastructure is a war crime
these were precision missiles aimed
at people
trying to
seek humanitarian shelter
not the first time in fact it's sadly a
repeat of many occasions when the
russian state
president putin and his generals
seek to take the war out on civilians
civilian areas and civilian national
infrastructure
whatever happens in ukraine we must not
let the international community forget
that
what putin is doing today
is building his own cage around himself
that sanctions
and his activities must not be freely
lifted to allow him to go back to his
super yachts and normality
what we are seeing is a criminal
endeavor
on a free and sovereign country
and britain and romania
and other nato allies will not stand by
and let that happen
i'm delighted to be here today as the
italian typhoon squadron hands over to
the royal air force united kingdom
uh win we will increase from four to six
the aircraft based here to do policing
the fact i'm standing next to british
and i think italian and certainly and
romanian allies
shows that strength in the air italy the
united states romania and the united
kingdom are playing a strong part in
protecting that domain under a spanish
commander from nato
truly multinational
on the land the united states france
belgium and portugal will be coming here
to assist and support
on the land components
finally i'll say something about the
united kingdom's role
when all of this is over people will ask
who were there before it happened and
who will be thereafter
united kingdom will be here after the
united kingdom was here before in
romania and in ukraine
and from the barrancy to the black sea
the united kingdom will play its part in
contributing to supporting the resolve
and strength of nato and standing up for
all those values in europe that we share
thank you
mr secretary of state i myself was under
the time pressure uh i do apologize for
that so um dear colleagues from the
media we are now opening the q a session
uh i would kindly ask you to try to
limit to one question and i'll follow up
if possible so the first question goes
to bbc
uh duncan kennedy from the bbc question
for both ministers please um a an
impressive show of force here this
morning but given that
we all understand that russia is
building up its forces again now for
another attack in ukraine do you think
this kind of thing could be seen as a
provocation or do you think that nato
simply has no choice now but to
demonstrate its force
[Music]
how do you provoke a man
who's already
invented excuse after excuse the excuse
to invade a sovereign country and kill
innocent villains you can't provoke him
anymore he is determined
at the cost of
ten you know thousands of russian lives
to
prosecute an invasion of a country that
he has no right to do so he doesn't care
about his own people the idea is going
to care about whether we fly jets uh in
our own airspace not their aspects no
one's flying into russian airspace in
our airspace
that is somehow provocative is is i
think misleading i think fundamentally
president putin
listens to strength
he listens eventually when the message
and the truth gets through to his people
to his people
and he will listen to the consequences
of what he has done in russia and
ukraine he will listen to the
consequences of his sanctions where is
the russian economy now where is the
ruble now where are his friends if his
friends are belarus and north korea and
venezuela
that's not a party i want to attend
that's not much of a friendship group
worth having
and i think he can't be provoked anymore
he can be deterred and we can help
ukraine defeat and push back his army
from their aggressive moves
and if he thinks he's got away with it
he only has to look at the casualty
rates of his young men that he sent
unprepared with an arrogance to war in
another country and look at the losses
of his armor open source suggests
they've lost two and a half thousand
armored vehicle
he's all in he has put most of his
russian ground forces into ukraine or on
the border of ukraine
and it doesn't look like it's gone very
well so far
yes he will try and regroup
yes he will try and re-equip but so will
the ukrainians with the help of nato
allies and donors they will be
re-equipped they will be resupplied
and the fundamental flaw in the russian
army hasn't gone away incompetent
generals arrogant generals arrogant
planning assumptions who don't care
about the men they command and not
caring about the menu command let me
tell you as a former soldier always ends
up
in the bad results which is what they're
getting
uh
many rules which seem to be abnormal
before the the conflict now are changing
evidence
clearly the world is changing and of
course the rules and also for the eu the
rules are changing
motivation
i saw the commitment of the eu to
support ukraine
with funds
to equip militarily ukrainian troops
[Music]
uh
we couldn't conceived uh previously this
uh
this kind of actions uh undertaken by
europe
conflict
[Music]
[Music]
i think during this conflict also uh the
eastern flank uh has changed its uh
attitude its uh commitment we can see
the uh the countries in the from the
eastern flank that uh they started uh
changing their behavior and asking the
entire international community to
support and strengthen the eastern flank
critical
strategies
[Music]
i think the nato strategy despite the
fact that it has changed progressively
it has shown a sort of coherence in all
the actions uh undertaken and it doesn't
uh it hasn't used pretext it practiced
this to undertake offensive actions
[Music]
the events such as the one in bucha
changes
radically
the attitude of the world towards
the
conflict second questions uh goes to sky
news
thank you joe pike from sky news uh
secretary of state
and you said there that targeting
civilian infrastructure is a war crime
are you saying explicitly that what has
happened in kramertorsk
is a war crime and what is the uk doing
in terms of lethal aid in response will
this include armored vehicles and will
this include anti-ship missiles
um
what constitutes a war crime is set out
in a range of statutes including the
geneva conventions etc
uh and
uh if proved then of course that power
russia would be guilty of the war crime
we've already seen
a number of allegations in
uh unlike the russian state we collect
evidence and then present that evidence
uh uh to be
approved uh to make sure that whether
someone's guilty or not of a war crime
that's the difference between them and
us
so as much as i'm tempted to say here
and now yes i think the key is
the circumstantial evidence absolutely
points to a range of war crimes being
committed by russia that's why we're
collecting the evidence that's why the
icc the national criminal court has
started collecting that process and
investigating that's why a number of
countries the united kingdom uh canada
etc are collecting that evidence but uh
i don't think there's any doubt if you
look at the previous record in syria and
grozny and places like that chechnya uh
that part of the russian playbook is
when it doesn't go well just start
taking it out on the civilians and
start destroying all the infrastructure
and there's always nothing left in mario
poll
as a result of russians ambitions
and i think that's what we shouldn't
forget this is not ukraine
fighting for
uh basic sort of dispute this is ukraine
fighting for its survival this is the
ukrainian people fighting for their
survival uh russia doesn't seem to care
about the infrastructures destroyed
america i'm not interested in that
and i think that's why it's worrying i
think i think the reality is that what
putin doesn't seem to recognize every
time he does this
the international community and let's
not forget the vote yesterday and the
human rights council to expel russia
actually responds the opposite of what
he wants you know there will be more
lethal aid as a result of this there
will be more
uh forces on the borders of nato there
may be more nato members as a result of
putin's actions that's what he got wrong
in 2014 is when he got wrong in 2008 the
consequences are always the opposite of
what he hopes to achieve and i think
i think what i will say is that
you know britain is continuous we're not
just going in
uh you know stops and starts our
commitment to support ukraine
is to make sure they have as much as
possible the help they need to defend
themselves and if the tactics of the
russians change what we give them will
change as well but all of us are leaning
in i've hosted two international donor
conference basili attended them as well
the number of states ranging from
portugal uh to the neighboring baltic
states have been contributing
significantly and that will continue i
won't discuss different types of weapons
systems
i don't want to flag to russians any
changes until they've happened
but you know we've already committed
from the end laws at the beginning
to the very high velocity missiles
anti-air missiles which was a step
increase which are now deployed and in
ukraine and if there's any more i'll
keep parliament updated
we still have time for two more
questions let's go
with uh
we've been hearing from defense
secretary ben wallace who's in romania
updating us um about what the uk is
going to be doing and following that
attack on the train station in crematosk
this morning then wallace said that
precision missiles aimed at people
trying to leave
were used which constitutes a war crime
he said that putin is building a cage
around himself and that sanctions must
not be lifted not least because putin
cannot be provoked anymore because he
doesn't care about his own people
we also heard from sky's joe pike
asking a question about war crimes and
what more weapons will be used we'll
hear from him a little bit later on